um this Talk's going to be about data
visualization and storytelling and
mostly data storytelling but before we
start I want to tell you a little bit
about me I'm a data scientist at God
it's driven we have a booth here if you
want to check it out there's actually
coding challenge there but I'm also here
on behalf of Pi data Amsterdam
um so keep in mind we are organizing a
pi data Amsterdam Conference next year
you'll hear much more about that
but besides those things which are quite
technical I'm also a hobbyist
Storyteller that means I like writing
stories creating stories and I always
used to think that creating stories was
something that was very separate from my
day-to-day job which is very technical
it's all about programming and you know
stories is like a creative thing
but I actually came to learn that data
visualization can be used to tell a
story as well so you can tell stories
with the data that you have
um so that's what I'll be telling you
about today how you can go a little bit
beyond regular exploratory data
visualization and actually use database
translation as a storytelling device
um but before we start I first want to
talk about what this talk is not going
to be about it's not going to be about
data visualization for data analysis so
if you want to get insights from your
data and you're looking for the best
ways to get those insights
um actually I think you probably have
that covered I'm not going to talk about
that specifically and I'm also not going
to talk about what the best plotting
library in python or Julia are is again
that's a preference thing I've created
all of the graphs that I have here just
with matplotlib they are much nicer to
use libraries out there probably and
much more fancy tools but everything
that we'll cover here today will be
about data visualization as a
storytelling device and it's not limited
to a specific tool or package
however what this talk will be about is
that I'm going to try to convince you
why data visualizations can do more than
just represent data and why data
visualizations can tell a story
and second of all I'm going to show you
what some simple steps are that you can
do even with the simplest of tools to
also tell the story that you want to
tell
so let's start at the beginning first of
all the importance of data visualization
why do we bother visualizing data to
begin with because some people have the
impression that charts are basically
just pretty pictures
while all the important information can
be found through statistical analysis
and summary statistics
but the best example why that's actually
not the case is these four data sets by
unscom which produce the exact same
summary statistics that means the mean
of the X and the Y and the correlation
and those kinds of things as all the
other data sets but only when you plot
them it actually shows that these are
very distinct and different data sets
so that means that if you have some
values like we have here an X and A Y
you can get to some summary statistics
which should tell you something about
the data probably but it's only when you
actually plot the data then it reveals
that this data set represents a dinosaur
this was a drawn dinosaur where all with
Cairo who's a great guy when it comes to
data visualization to illustrate the
importance of visualizing your data to
get insights
and this point was even further
emphasized with the article same stats
different grass graphs where they
exactly use the same summary statistics
to produce 13 different data sets that
all lead to clearly different visual
representations but if you just look at
the summary statistics they look exactly
the same
so
um visualization matters we know that
now
you probably also knew that but why what
does that have to do with data
storytelling well first of all there are
two different kinds of data
visualization
you have plots like this the one that we
have here which is a simple scatter plot
made with multiple lip and it is used
probably to get some insight into our
data to add to those insights but then
we also have data visualizations like
the one over there and this is clearly a
different type of data visualization all
of the visualization that you see here
the colors of the bars the titles the
orientation of the bars it's it all
automatically leads you to a certain
conclusion you don't even have to look
at the exact numbers that are on here to
know what this graph is trying to tell
you
and it also means that we can very
simply flip that message just by
changing some of those aspects we change
the title we change the color we change
the orientation and even though these
these two graphs show exactly the same
data they lead you to a widely different
conclusion
and this illustrates that there is in
fact two different types of data
visualization the first chart we saw the
simple multiple clip chart is a clear
example of exploratory data
visualization it is a graph that we use
or plot that we make because we have
some hypothesis about our data we
believe for instance that the customer
satisfaction has gone up through our
marketing campaign and we try to verify
that hypothesis by experimenting a lot
producing different plots and getting
some more insights
whereas the second graph is an example
of explanatory data visualization it is
not meant to explore the data it is not
meant to get an insight into the data
it's meant to communicate a certain very
specific insight
and it turns out that the best
exploratory visualization is not
necessarily the best explanatory
visualization either
when you are exploring your data you
have the luxury of time so you can
produce a plot but you've probably also
seen some summary statistics you also
make some different plots you can
analyze the plot that you're looking at
to look for the patterns that you see in
your data there because you have that
time because your analysis analyzing
your data but when you're communicating
about your data when you have found that
Insight through exploratory data
analysis and you want to tell someone
you want it to be immediately clear from
the visualization that you're presenting
what their conclusion should be or what
they should take from this graph
and it goes beyond that because you
probably don't only want to show that
you did some work with that
visualization you want to start a
discussion or you want to lead into a
certain conclusion
and that's what explanatory data
visualization is about
because explanatory data visualization
tells a story
so maybe your analysis revealed that
recent changes to a marketing campaign
improved the way that people look at
your company and therefore you want to
start a discussion of whether to
continue with that or recommend to
continue with that or maybe you've
discovered that chickens grow the best
on a certain diet and therefore you
recommend continuing with that
the point is an explanatory data
visualization isn't there to be pretty
um it's there to support a point and
while data may be objective the
decisions that you make on how to
present that data also shapes the story
that you're telling
look at this chart for example this is a
chart about the population growth in the
past 60 years and it looks like there's
there's quite a well there's quite an
increase of population growth maybe
looks a bit worrying
but if you look at the other graph which
is from the exact same data set but we
chose the limits of the graph a little
bit different it tells a different story
it tells oh it's getting really critical
here
and I believe that our role as data
storytellers is to bridge the gap
between clinical and analytical data and
tell a story while keeping true to the
facts so how can you make your
visualization in such a way that we
focus on this discussion that we want to
have the point that we want to make
without being misleading
so how can we tell a story with her data
like I said I'm a hobbyist Storyteller I
like writing stories and what we usually
think about when we think about Stories
the three aspects which are not just
beginning with one and are the place or
the context in which the story takes
place the people or the characters in
the story and the purpose or the
motivation of the story itself
and when we think about data
storytelling we don't necessarily of
course have a place or people but we're
also focusing on three things first of
all on the foundation of the
visualization so how do we choose to
represent the data itself and what
decisions do we make there
Focus what kind of characteristics can
we add to our graph or plot to direct
the focus of the reader to the point
where we want their attention
and third forward why am i showing
someone this graph or this plot what
discussion do I want to start or what do
I want them to conclude from this and
that's also what I'll be focusing on in
this presentation
so we'll start with the foundation of
course so this is about how do you
choose the right chart and how do you
choose to represent your data
of course there are lots of different
charts out there there are line plots
Scatter Plots pie charts bar charts lots
of other types of plots as well
and while all of them have some purpose
and are good in certain circumstances
some charts are better in certain
conditions than others
for example if we look at these two
charts they represent the exact same
information but if you had to choose
which one was clearer to get the trend
from is that option A or option D I
would say that option A is the better
choice here because it's it's more
obvious when you're looking at it with
the trend over time is
that doesn't mean that bar charts are
bad it just means that for this for
communicating insights about the trend
maybe the bar chart isn't the right
choice
and the same goes for these two graphs
again they show exactly the same
information
um but if you're interested in seeing
what is the largest uh Mark chair I
think the second one is a little bit
clearer because in the first one the
blocks look roughly the same size when
it's in the second one you can see that
it's just a bit bigger would it even
help to have a little grid on the
background there
so the question is how do you determine
the right turn for your use case well I
would say there are two things you can
do there first of all which I really
recommend anyone just do is
experimentation and experimentation
means that you have a specific thing in
mind that you want to communicate for
instance I want to open a conversation
about the trend and for instance I think
it's going down and you choose a couple
of different charts and see which one
immediately seems the most sensible but
also it doesn't make sense to reinvent
the wheel all the time so something that
I found very helpful as well is this
chart by chartguide.com poster which
tells you about all the different chart
types and which ones are good in certain
in certain circumstances this is
actually kind of a very small version of
it the entire poster is a lot bigger and
I wholeheartedly recommend it
but even if you choose the right chart
there's still a couple of things
regarding how you represent the data
that you also should keep in mind
but first
it's important is to make sure that your
reader or the person who you're
presenting to is familiar with your type
of chart
this might sound very obvious but a
mistake that I very often see happening
is that you know we as data scientists
we like things like confidence intervals
and error labels and those kinds of
things because they give you a lot more
insight into the data they give you some
idea about how precise the management is
they can give you ideas about new things
and new hypothesis you have to try out
but it's probably a little bit too
cluttered and not very clear for the
person who you're presenting to is
usually not necessarily a data scientist
so for example
um box plots takes these Bots plots for
example these are box plots that
represent the attack value for all the
different Pokemon types and they
communicate a lot more they also
communicate not just the mean or the
median but they also something about the
range of the values there
um and there's just a lot going on here
so when I show you this as data
scientists you probably recognize box
plots but box plots are not as common
outside of exploratory data analysis as
you might think so if you have something
like this on a slide you're probably
also going to have to show this in the
slide before where you explain how the
interquartile range is calculated how
that relates to the lower whisker and
the maximum whisper and what kind of
conclusions you can draw from that and
if you have to show this before you show
the box plots you're probably going to
lose your audience there so it's not a
very clear way to clearly communicate
the second point is
choose the data to display carefully
so we already saw that in this example
where the limits and the range of the
axis actually makes a lot of difference
in first impression that you get from
the chart
and this might be obvious but it's
something to really keep in mind and
very often when you make a visualization
even if if it's an easy visualization
you have a lot of choices there that you
have to make for instance these are
again three examples of the exact same
data set where it's about the total
sales of two booksellers
and in the first one even though you can
read the axis and you can draw the
conclusions from that your first
impression is going to be that
Bookseller a is a lot more successful
than Bookseller B whereas if you change
the ranges to start at zero like you
should
um the difference becomes a lot smaller
and if you then change it again because
you're no longer in the uh representing
the axis in the volume but you represent
it in the percentages the bars for
Bookseller a and Bookseller B look even
more closely together so by simply
changing the range and the units you go
from Bookseller a is a lot more
successful to well they're kind of about
similarly successful so again
the way you represent your data in that
sense matters
and another thing that you should also
take into account is how you choose to
deal with data that you're not
representing a very common mistake that
you see especially with elections in in
the media is that when the first results
are getting in they represent the chart
like this where you can see oh
apparently Clinton is doing a lot better
than Trump but actually that is a
conclusion that you're drawing from this
graph
but that's not a conclusion that you can
dry out because a lot of the data is not
in yet so these again these two graphs
give off a very different impression
and as daily storytellers unlike fiction
storytellers we have an obligation to
stay close to the truth
that being said let's move on to the
second topic let's say that you have the
right chart you know how to represent
your data how can we lead the focus or
the gravity attention of the reader and
point it towards the part of the chart
that we want them to look at
for this I'm going to do a little
experiment on the next slide I'm going
to show you a bunch of numbers and I
want you to count the amount of fives
that you see here
ready
all right how was that
um you probably could find papayas in
here but it took you a little bit of
time because you had to sift through all
of the information that you saw here
however if I represent the exact same
information in a slightly different way
like this it's probably much easier to
spot the fives which is where I want to
draw your attention to
and color is not the only thing that can
lead your attention somewhere for
instance if we look at shapes the ones
and the eights here are in the exact
same spots but the ones are probably
easier to spot than the eights because
the shape is more distinctly different
when we are creating data visualization
for explanatory purposes we probably
have something specific in mind that we
want to communicate and if we use
visualization
um uh the visualization that we use to
get that Insight it's probably going to
be too cluttered and you have to explain
to people where to look whereas you can
also direct the attention of the person
that you're presenting to to the right
thing
for example if we have a graph like this
one over here where we have the goals of
the European championships in the group
phase
um it's a nice graph it's one that I
would use for exploratory purposes but
why am i showing you this what's
interesting about it what is it that
stood out to me that I want to tell you
it's not exactly clear because there's a
lot going on here
however
if I change this one thing which is the
color your attention will immediately be
drawn towards the Netherlands and you'll
probably see that I want to talk about
how much better the Netherlands was in
the group phase in terms of goals than
the other countries that were competing
however in this case I would say red is
not a good color to use because red has
this Association of danger and bad so we
probably want to go for something a
little bit more positive
green for instance
I said green is also not a great color
here because it it's too similar to the
blues so you probably notice that it
doesn't stand out as much as the red did
so a better alternative here would be to
choose a more representative color
like orange
the color associated with the
Netherlands of course
and you can even draw more attention to
this orange bar by making the other
parts of the graph a graph less
noticeable
by giving them less color
but it's not just color that you can
change if I want to make a point I'm
also able to adjust this chart even more
to make that point for instance I can
give a little bit of context about the
situation here so by adding a line and
some text to the chart in this case a
line that indicates what the maximum
number of goals in a group phase was
four years earlier
and it seems here that quite a few
countries were quite above that line so
maybe it makes sense if you want to say
make a point about how much more
competitive this group phase was for
instance by highlighting those as well
again that is something that we can
emphasize with colors and if you compare
this visualization to the one that we
started with
it's quite different just by changing
the colors adding some text adding a
line
um you can convey a lot of information
and the visualization immediately allows
you to draw some conclusions was the
first one probably just allows you to
look at it to look for those conclusions
yourself
something to keep in mind though when
you're adding colors is that a lot of
the visualization libraries have some
default colors and those default colors
are usually chosen to be good or
appropriate for colorblind people so
don't deviate from those kinds of things
too much
but we are not restricted to just using
lines of text or lines of colors it can
also really help to create a title for
instance in this case we have language
most languages most popular subjects in
class 3A this is a data set about a
survey that was done among class
students of class 3A and they were asked
do you like this subject or don't you
like it and if you have a title like
this which is positive you're probably
going to verify that title by looking at
the first few entries first
whereas if you have the opposite title
stem not very popular among class 3A
you're probably going to focus on the
last few subjects here
so title is another very effective way
of guiding the reader's attention and
you can of course combine that with all
the previous things that we talked about
for instance what you see here by adding
color
and adding a line of information by
adding more context to the graph itself
because of some simple design choices
your attention is guided to a completely
different part of the graph in both of
these or a different part of the data in
both of these graphs and whereas the one
on the this one over here is focusing on
the positive on the the most like
languages the one on the other side is
focusing on the negative
which brings me to my next point forward
we want to guide someone's attention to
a certain part of the data
because we are communicating something
and there's a reason for that
communication
if I just show you a graph and it's I'm
not saying what we're going to do with
it and it just focus your attention it's
very nice but why am i showing you this
so the question you should always ask is
what should be the takeaway from your
visualization what is the one thing that
you want people to take away or what
action do you want them to take that can
be either convincing them to make a
certain choice to recommend continuing
with something or to this to start a
discussion about how to you know improve
something but there should be a point or
a purpose to your visualization because
without an action no matter how nice
your visualization is people are likely
to forget it because there's no reason
to remember it
so if you have a visualization like this
again it's it's not it's interesting
it's nice to know but there's no
takeaway here
and the same thing here it looks a bit
more negative like I'm focusing clearly
on the part that is not good but why am
I focusing on that part and what do I
want you to do with this
well one thing that really helps is just
simply change the title to something a
lot more active so the previous title
was very descriptive it was showing you
what to focus on but in this case we
change the title to something more
active and the thing that I would like
to discuss with you and active titles
really helped there so we must we should
something along those we need something
on those lines
if you really want to focus on why
you're showing a certain visualization
it usually helps to do three things
first of all put the message itself
first so make the title big and bold and
about why you are showing this
then put your supporting point and your
supporting point is the visualization
this visualization is here to support
the point that we need to change the way
that we we teach these subjects to this
class
and we don't just show the visualization
the initial visualization but we add two
or three things that really guide your
attention to the right spot so in this
case the title already guides you to the
right spot of the data the colors and
the line that was added immediately
focuses your attention
and then it really helps to emphasize
the action as well you don't have to put
that under your graph but it usually
doesn't hurt it can also just be a story
that you tell along with your data but
when you show something like this I
don't even have to say anything yet and
you will all know what this
visualization is going to be about
whereas if I show you the original
visualization I would have to tell you
what I was thinking and what the story
was
so and with that you've converted a
simple insight into an actionable one
and one that you can effectively
communicate
because data storytelling is the art of
successfully communicating about data
and hopefully my talk today has made
that a little bit easier for you with a
good chart as a foundation and the right
data choices there
knowing that you can use title or colors
or text to very easily Focus the
attention and lastly to a way to present
how to move forward hopefully you will
be able to tell a story with your data
um yeah thank you for having me here
today I hope I've inspired you to tell
stories with your data if you found this
interesting and you actually want to
know a lot more about how to do this I
work for godative driven and we have an
academy and there's actually a data
visualization a storytelling course that
we offer regularly so that's something
to check out maybe
but otherwise I'll be here at the
conference the whole day so please come
up and talk to me if this is a topic
that you find interesting
thank you all very much
very well done also nicely within the
time I think Marine already asked the
question
yeah go for it what's the name of the
dog end there
from the bookenders game
thank you great talk I uh I tried to put
a picture of my dog in every
presentation that I do as you should as
you should respect
you have any other
questions
otherwise I was wondering
um like I used to work in research and
there some of the research group would
have an actual creative person on the
team like an artist that would help them
make their
visualization because researchers
tend to be not very creative people yes
it's a difficult combination to get and
do you think that is something
that like companies or research groups
could benefit from like actually having
a person who knows how to visualize
things on the team yeah so the thing is
when you present things to people and
when you present a visualization a lot
of the things about focus is about
grabbing their attention and a nice
picture grabs people's attention more
than not nice pictures too so it's nicer
to have a nicer visualization but I and
but I chose to do everything with my
little lib here because for me for a
very long time I knew how to make
exploratory data analysis visualizations
and I thought well if I may want to make
pretty pictures I'm just not creative
enough for that I don't know how to do
it I don't know the tools but it turns
out there's a couple of small things
that can really help you create more
compelling visualizations with tools
that are not as complicated so yeah if I
wanted to put something on the website I
probably would ask someone who's a bit
more first in the whole creative thing
to make something that's nicer than a
month of lip plots but I do think that I
was able to improve the pictures that I
was offering with some very simple
things so that's why it's decided to
focus on that I think companies can
benefit from it but it I don't think
it's about tooling and I think we as
data scientists we have to not only
understand the data but also be able to
talk about the data with other people
and hopefully this helps in that respect
yeah so it's a skill that data
scientists should work on as well yeah
like at least be a little bit more
creative with your graphs yeah don't
think oh I I don't know how to make
those those really cool infographics
like one of the ones that I showed so I
don't have to bother with this at all
there's a few simple things that you can
do as well
definitely
mark
thank you great presentation I think it
shouldn't come as a surprise that a
presentation about data storytelling is
really put well together sort of good
compliments um and indeed effects don't
speak for themselves I think you
Illustrated that uh I was just wondering
um could you name any instances or
examples of cases where you were like
this is definitely not the way to go
right
maybe even a misrepresentation of uh
yeah so I don't have a very concrete
example but I do know that if I look
back in my own career as a data
scientist I've often been asked to to
tell like put together a presentation or
a PowerPoint about something and you
know that things are not going well when
you put an image in there and you spend
like five minutes explaining what people
should see on the image I think that's
when you're not doing it right basically
thank you
we have any more takers for the cube
over there
oh
hey so I think this power also comes
with the responsibility right you can
also lie
with really good data visualization
right and what's your take on on that
yeah I think that's a very good point so
that was something I was a little bit
worried about when I was putting
together my presentation because I
thought oh but I don't want to tell a
bunch of people how they can manipulate
what people think through these you know
they give them ideas no because this of
course this is the kind of thing that
very easily also leads to a
misrepresentation it also gives you the
tools to misrepresent your data and
mislead to to force people towards a
certain conclusion even though
I don't think that that's what you
should be doing so that's why I said
unlike fiction storytellers data
storytellers do have an obligation to
stay as close as possible to the facts
to the data I think you can direct focus
and start a conversation through that
but don't misrepresent the facts I yeah
don't do that unfortunately you can do
that with everything that I told you but
please don't
huh any more questions anyone want to
catch the cube
I think you just had a very clear talk
then well thank you all for having me
yeah thank you for being here